I have been doing blood glucose monitoring for a state of the morning. My numbers have
been 108 to 117. Okay, that's not good. So, I don't mean to scare you, but that's pre-diabetic.
That's syndrome X. That's where we want to be. So, and people will go, so you might be thinking
this, how in the world I eat like this perfect diet? I don't eat any sugar. How in the world
can I be pre-diabetic? Because it's, it's not just your diet that can damage the cell membranes.
So, the reason why a person has elevated glucose, the reason why a person has type 2 diabetes
is because the glucose can't get into the cell because the membranes of the cell have, are damaged
and the receptors, the insulin receptors, the cell membranes are damaged. So, what could cause
that? Well, you know, a poor diet could cause that. Eating weight, a poor diet, let's, let's break
it down to pieces. A poor diet, you wait too much sugar over a period of time could cause that
because it's just, it overstabulates the receptors. The insulin receptors are the cell membranes
and other receptors just don't work very well. But that's not always the case. Some people
have eaten a wonderful diet and they end up developing type 2 diabetes. Well, how is that?
It can be because of other exposures to chemicals and things that affect and damage that receptor
that is a due to an excess sugar consumption. So, that can damage the
receptors on the cell membrane. And then lastly, we're talking about type 2 diabetes.
Of course, it has type 1 diabetes. That's totally different. It's completely different disease. So,
this is not type 1 diabetes. This is a diabetes, but this is prediabetic because really your
fasting blood glucose should be under 100. Now, we want to get it down into the 70s. That's what we
want to get it down to. So, we got to look at, you know, and everybody's an individual here. So,
if a person is like, I only weigh 106 pounds as it is, was boss to stop eating any carbohydrates?
No, no. So, there's certain things that Trump getting our blood glucose down into the 70s.
And what is that we don't want to put ourselves in a state of caeccia. So, we have to be
cognizant of that before we make that next decision. So, baby, we should have a chat.